bonjour aller vite retrouver françois il
vous attend
bonjour aujourd'hui nous sommes en train
de parler de collection pierre tu fais
une collection de quoi collection pierre
de pièces une collection de pièces et
toi michael collection d'insectes c'est
formidable ça et toi françois des
collections de lier leurs jolies salut
casimir tu vas bien mais non pas du tout
regarde comme je suis pas mal
j'avais pas remarqué tu es malade non
mais regarde quoi françois mais oui je
ne comprends pas pourquoi il me déteste
et qu'il ne m'a pas attendu il ne te
déteste pas dit mais alors pourquoi at
il commencé un jeu sans ma corde mais il
n'a pas commencé à je sais françois
pierre et mickaël qui lui ont rapporté
leurs collections et justement il
t'attend pour les montrer à nos amis
ah bon c'est vrai oui je vais beaucoup
mieux alors merci je suis allé voir mon
frère françois de casino que se
passe-t-il il est arrivé un accident
mais non mais je suis là tu peux
commencer à montrer les connexions
voyons que fumer c'est vrai que nous
attendions mais nous étions en pleine
discussion et tu nous interrompue
vraiment tu es trop capricieux mon vieux
c'est pas parce que tu arrives que nous
devons commencer à montrer la collection
immédiatement mais si avant et pourquoi
s'il te plaît mais mais parce que je
suis le dernier à venir tout le monde
est là alors qu'il n'a pas traîné
c'est vraiment ce que tu penses ouais et
alors que voulez-vous répondre à ça bon
alors on commence
oui oui casimir on y va hier
qu'ils me parlent de tacler santé est
gelée commencé un jour j'ai trouvé dans
un grenier un petit quart temps avec pas
mal de pièces qui étaient assez ancien
le pièce on ne pensait pas envoyer
souvent qu'est ce qu'il valait plus ou
alors on connaissait des gens qui
veulent notre pays qui avaient des
pièces antiques se sert le cul alors
j'ai pensé qu'il faut faire une
collection
il était venu de faire une collection de
pièces tu sais comme on appelle une
personne qui fait collection de pièces
un numismate à des anémies ce matin
montre moi quelques pièces dont il est
très fier lune qui brille martin pièces
de la pole est au point elle est en quoi
en bronze y en a d'autres oui ça plaise
particulièrement qu'est ce qu'on sait
c'est que c'est joli et écouter le
motiver c'est vrai mais elle est très
belle mais elle est très ancienne des
pièces aux grilles de récentes dans la
collection montre là celle ci est très
jolie si tu devais les collections des
spas casinos sienne michael tu me parler
de ta collection le cas des soucis de
deux failles qui se sont sur des
charbons charbon de faille à oui on voit
très nettement l'empreinte celui-ci par
le mot celui ci je trouve magnifique
si oui un gros coquillage est il
l'auteur qui rentrait dedans oui on voit
un coup là petit à petit tout petit lac
ou la terre ces faits pierre est tenu
d'un certain moment le coquillage qui
était dessus est parti et puis il reste
et l'empreinte l'image fixe j'espère que
tu n'as pas de fossiles de casimir woods
ah bon et là bas qu'est ce que c'est
c'est le csah saint martin oui c'est toi
qui l'a trouvé tu l'as trouvé au sur la
plage sur la plage une très belle
collection
si vous voyez la collection de françois
maintenant une connexion wi fi du pyrite
ça c'est si du clos du plomb acide ispat
sur l'un fait du dentifrice
oui qu'est ce que tu as et intéresse
particulièrement notable excès du quartz
pas toutes les pièces se plaisent je
pense ça c'est du quartz et du lait tu
les trouves commenter les pierres contre
les offres des fois oui j'en demande où
il est trop bu et fois cette fois encore
des pierres
et qu'est ce qui t'intéresse dans le
fait de faire une collection c'est joli
c'est joli et puis on apprend je pense
aussi énormément de choses sur la nature
bien voilà trois collections fort belle
vous êtes de grands collectionneurs
étaient licites
bonsoir oui tu viens de dire à la pierre
la france prend et mickaël qu'ils
étaient des grands collectionneurs
mais existe-t-il des très grands
collectionneurs que tu dire que 10000 et
bien un grand collectionneur est un
grand collectionneur bien taillé dans le
collectionneur est un collectionneur
plus grand qu'un grand collectionneur
attaque très grave dire plus grand que
grande mais tu as tout à fait
raisonnable membres alors tu n'as pas
répondu à ma question existe-t-il des
très grands collectionneurs pardon à mu
oui bien sûr qu'ils y mourir selon non
ils vont bien existé là le plus grand
collectionneur du monde c'est certain
bon j'aurais dit fier de le connaître
évidemment tu le connais non pas encore
mais je crois que je le connais très
bientôt
[Musique]
à
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour il faut que je cache ceci avant
que julie et françois ne le vois je vais
le mettre dans la dans la malle magique
voilà je ne peux pas vous le montrer
pour l'instant mais vous le verrez tout
à l'heure voilà
julie bonjour papa casimir bonjour mais
on sait déjà vu tout à l'heure un oui
c'est vrai 1 qu'est ce que tu cherches à
attraper à à le bocal de caramel
non non non on sait j'en veux bien mais
ce n'est pas ce que je cherchais à
attraper ma bon mais alors qu'est ce que
tu veux mais bien d'obinna bonbons
fourrés à la framboise c'est pas ça non
alors c'est délicieux sucre d'orge non
non plus et bien alors je ne sais pas
moi une trajet au point pas du tout
écoute casimir je donne ma langue au
chat
je n'ai pas le temps de jouer aux
devinettes je travaille les coups de
julie et là je vais te le dire à
l'oreille alors j'écoute les mollahs
larinto mais vos boutons mais tu es fou
casimir meilleur si jolie supérieur très
bons boutons et casimir
enfin ça alors c'est incroyable mais tu
sais françois si tu savais ce que
casimir vient de me faire mais mes
cuisses et il sait jamais comme c'est
joli mais je crois que l'équipe l'indien
mi temps mais oui je n'ai pas perdu à
casimir qui me l'a arraché
il ne s'est pas excusé de cette maladie
c'est pas une maladresse il l'a fait
exprès exprès oui mais pourquoi le pire
c'est que je ne le sais pas non mais je
vais lui demander des comptes mois il
faudra bien qu'il me donne une
explication essaie de récupérer un bon
bouton - d'accord
casino je voudrais que par les casinos
fois je voulais justement peut voir des
boutons s'il te plaît mais pourquoi
et parce que je n'ai pas envie que tu
m'as rachat doute au comme il l'a fait à
julie ah bon je crois que je vais avoir
du mal à lui prendre un mouton mais mais
je me dis qu'elle aimait boyer gutkès
que ça pour excuse moi françois mais
c'est un terrible malentendu je n'ai pas
fait exprès d'inde arracher un bouton à
julie pourtant d'après ce qu'il a dit
mais je t'assure écoute je vais te
montrer exactement comment ça s'est
passé
oui tu as raison avant de seconde et je
dois te permettre de t'expliquer vézard
françois tu vraiment mon meilleur ami
oui mais vous savez ça va ça va ça va
aller donne moi ton explication
alors voilà tiens toi bien droit les
bras le long du corps
pour quoi faire ah ben une
reconstitution pour te montrer
exactement comment est l'état il faut
que tu sois dans la même position et tu
as tout à fait raison ballon bouge plus
comme ça ça va me voilà donc je me suis
approchée doucement de julie et hop je
viens arracher son bouton d'août aux
états unis mais tu es fou
ahaha bravo c'est une très bonne
reconstitution c'est exactement ce que
julie manille
alors regarde toi aussi m'a alors dit
don c'est vraiment incroyable mais je
comprends plus rien oh mes amis je suis
content de vous voir il se passe des
choses très graves dans l'île aux
enfants raconte évite recteur c'est bien
mais pas aux amis casimir est devenu fou
je viens de parcourir l'île pour ma
tournée je n'ai rencontré que des gens
des gens affolés casimir les avait
attaqués
oui colrat hanche et un bouton de leur
veste ou de leur robe regard des
facteurs au comment ça mais avoue aussi
là osé on sent leur tracteur bonjour une
approche 3 casimir la proche forêt
dragon facteurs je ne voudrais pas
demain non quand même que j'aimerais que
vous regardiez un oiseau qui est l'un
des oiseaux aux boutons le bouton casino
charles houle j'ai honte d'être ton ami
mais pourquoi on se rencontrèrent qui
devrait être fier de moi fier inde a
sûrement pas mais si tu as bien dit tout
à l'heure que tu aimerais rencontrer le
plus grand collectionneur du monde
et bien voilà je suis le plus grand
collectionneur de boutons du monde
[Musique]